[Musique]
tu vivre de sa passion
et bien c'est sortir du cadre
toute ma vie je suis sorti du cadre
toute ma vie j'ai voulu être différent
ne pas être dans le moule être vraiment
différent et surtout être indépendant
qu'est ce que c'est bon d'être
indépendant tu travailles comme tu veux
tu vas où tu veux n'a de compte à rendre
à personne
le lundi est un samedi le dimanche et à
mercredi
tout est remis en question bon vous
allez me dire et l'argent dans tout ça
et oui l'argent c'est important l'argent
quand et indépendant je voulais
recentrer quand même quand je dis
indépendance et être à son compte
c'est un peu comme tu veux en fait tu
peux choisir de travailler juste ce
qu'il faut pour boucler des fins de mois
où tu peux inversement
travailler trois fois plus de manière
acharnée et avoir suffisamment de moyens
pour l'état famille partir en vacances
et même mettre de côté pour tes vieux
jours
ça devait penser en tant qu'indépendant
en tant qu'artiste à ces soirées où je
rencontre de nouvelles personnes et on
me demande ce que je fais dans la vie
aïe c'est là que c'est dur c'est pas dur
pour moi mais dès que j'annonce que je
suis artiste peintre je sens une sorte
de compassion s'installer
comme si j'avais annoncé que j'étais au
chômage ils font la même tête comme si
j'étais au chômage
et le comble c'est que je m'éclate dans
la vie je voyage dans le monde entier
je fais ce que j'aime mais je pense que
le process d'être à son compte comme ça
artiste-peintre on a du mal à comprendre
le mécanisme et c'est presque trop beau
pour être vrai mais finalement vivre de
sa passion
c'est pas le rêve de chacun
que feriez vous si vous pouviez vivre de
votre passion cette question je me suis
posé très jeune à l'école en primaire
moi j'étais plutôt quelqu'un de pas très
docile on me disait lucas tu préfères le
bleu ou le rouge je disais noir suit les
règles mais en fait très jeune je
voulais écrire mes propres règles je
voulais pas qu'on m'impose des choses
alors je regardais par la fenêtre et
j'ai oublié de fermer de voir ma mère
m'engueuler c'est pas bien mais moi je
voulais juste m'amuser en fait mais je
me suis posé cette question pourquoi
devrions-nous forcément faire un travail
un métier socialement bien perçu si
j'aime courir par exemple pourquoi je
pourrais pas faire un métier en ce sens
pourquoi on pourrait pas associé la
passion et le travail au collège j'étais
extrêmement dissipée forcément un
primaire j'étais casse-bonbons collège
ça a suivi on me répétait sans cesse
lucas je continue comme ça tu vas finir
en apprentissage
en apprentissage parce qu apprendre un
métier à 14 ans c'est la pire des tares
franchement mois à 14 ans j'étais obsédé
par le skate vous savez la planche à
roulettes qui fait du bruit et voisins
qui vont m'arrêter oui je me ferai des
seaux d'eau sur la tête mais j'aimais ça
j'aimais tellement le skateboard que je
voulais en faire ma vie imaginez la tête
de ma conseillère d'orientation qui me
demande ce que je veux faire plus tard
professionnels de skate mais du cas
sérieux sérieusement
elle m'a pas dit sérieux mais
sérieusement la planche à roulettes
c'est pas un métier
pourquoi pas choisir banquiers docteurs
avocats et pourquoi pas sur rossi et
attend déconne pas quand même moi
j'avais envie de faire quelque chose de
ma vie
très jeune du coup à 14 ans a bandé naïf
quand même et je l'écoutais et je suis
parti dans le magnifique cursus de
l'enseignement général vraiment très
général super j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses mais j'ai été assidu et j'ai eu
mon diplôme de business administration
je sais toujours pas ce que c'est
d'ailleurs
malgré ça je me suis dit luca c'est pas
parce que tu as un business
administration que tu peux pas faire
quelque chose que tu aimes faire quelque
chose qui a du sens pour toi me réaliser
moi-même je vais vous raconter comment
j'ai réussi à vivre de ma passion son
tuto sans règles mais avec une grande
ambition et surtout une abnégation sans
limite
ma passion pour le skateboard m'a offert
mon premier job
tiens ça me fait penser à ma conseillère
d'orientation qui s'était moqué de moi
petit petit un petit clin d'oeil
pourrait d'ailleurs donc à la sortie de
mes études
un pote de lycée me propose de
l'accompagner dans le développement d'un
magazine de skate
imaginez ma tête trop bien c'est bon je
me lance dans un tel cas ce qu est ce
que j'aime
sauf que moi je n'avais aucune notion de
de l'édition ou de journalisme mais
j'étais possédé par l'idée de faire
quelque chose que j'aime donc ce
magazine sur la culture skate les débuts
chaotiques je dirais même hardcore
j'avais aucun contact
du coup je feuilleter les pages jaunes
pour trouver un numéro quand j'appelais
marques ont raccroché au nez quand
j'avais la chance de la voir d'ailleurs
et puis nous les torts décalé quoi c'est
à dire qu'on avait un magazine bourré de
fautes ont piqué les photos sur internet
du coup bas les photos étaient pixelisé
mais on savait même pas qu'on n'avait
pas droit de le faire
les félins d'autorisation de
photographes ne savait pas on était
vraiment on apprenait sur le terrain un
jour on est parti sur un salon et on a
décidé de montrer de magazines parce
qu'on était fier ce soir on va montrer
de magasinier terminé il est beau je
distribue à tout le monde est au bout de
une demi heure on me montre du doigt
comme ça je fais les gars c'est nouveau
il y eu l'impression que c'est nous et
en fait on était la risée la risée du
salon tout le monde se moquait de nous
ils ont dit baser le magazine c'est un
torchon rempli de fautes et là j'ai vu
une grosse claque
j'étais fier d'eux on était fiers de
nous et finalement on était à l'ouest
complet du coup
on s'est dit ok faut se prendre en main
faut se battre faut s'arracher
parce que nous on est des outsiders et
finalement la place de outsider c'est
pas mal parce que c'est là que tu
t'arraches et que tu t'améliores huit
ans d'acharnement plus tard on est passé
du petit le vilain petit canard
distribuer sur la côte d'azur à une
référence mondiale le téléphone sonnait
toute la journée
alors on va annoncer à l'eau avons
annoncé on l'éteint on était invitée
partout dans le monde on voyait nos
héros dans le skateboard dont les
rencontrer et on l'a vécu une expérience
extraordinaire et cette anecdote c'est
vraiment ma prouver qu' il fallait se
battre trois fois plus en fait et même
si tu fais un bon travail il faut
toujours se dire que tu peux faire mieux
tout remettre en question
après huit ans passés sur le magazine
belle expérience j'ai eu envie de voler
mes propres ailes
c'est à dire toutes abandonnées sans
plan a plan b ni plan c je me jette dans
le vide
parce que moi j'avais envie d'être
différent encore plus différent
j'avais envie de faire vraiment quelque
chose qui avait du sens pour moi pour me
donner bonne conscience j'ai quand même
ouvert mon ordi parce que il paraît que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
on ouvre son ordi on cherche du travail
je vais sur les sites justement où on
propose des offres et pour moi là ça a
été un moment de solitude
j'ai fait mais c'est comme ça que ça se
passe c'est l'horreur du coup ce que
j'ai fait c'est que j'ai fermé le redis
j'ai jeté par la fenêtre et j'ai pleuré
même pas parce que leur dites est cassé
j'ai pleuré parce que je me suis rendu
compte qu'il était enfin temps pour moi
de vivre la vie que je voulais vivre
j'ai pris une feuille un crayon j'ai
dessiné un triangle sur lequel j'ai
inscrit les trois choses qui avaient le
plus de sens pour moi
le skate les voyages et là sans savoir
je venais de définir ma vie en tout cas
je venais de chambouler ma vie à jamais
je sais pas vous mais moi je n'ai jamais
cru en la chance d'être tiré au sort
vous savez on gratte un ticket j'espère
que je vais gagner sont remises pour
partir en vacances
en fait celle inverse j'ai toujours cru
à l'idée de se prendre en mains de se
fixer des objectifs et les atteindre du
coup ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris mes
trois passions l'art le skateboard et
les voyages et j'en ai fait un concept
j'ai rassemblé des artistes du monde
entier et on s'est réunis en europe on a
voyagé amsterdam londres copenhague
barcelone paris et on a présenté nos
oeuvres
donc ça c'est pas mon travail mon tout
cas c'est le travail d'un des artistes
qui est que j'ai ramené dans ce projet
et nous avons vécu une expérience
extraordinaire
quand je dis extraordinaire c'était
humainement extraordinaire nous avons
été ensemble pendant un an à voyager en
europe
mon traîneau en oeuvre et au delà de de
ce qu'on avait à présenter
artistiquement on a vécu une expérience
extraordinaire y avait un mexicain il y
avait un australien il y avait un
hollandais et on a partagé un moment
fort on va parler de nos cultures
c'était vraiment intense suite à ce
projet je me suis dit que je voulais
aller plus loin en fait comme je suis né
dedans les années 80 et que j'ai grandi
donc dans les années 90 la seule façon
pour moi de me de m'informer
comme tout le monde ici si vous êtes
tenir la période c'était d'acheter des
magazines
j'avais des tonnes de magazines dans ce
cas est le snowboard le surf les sports
de glisse et y en avait partout et puis
je suis devenu fan justement aux deux ça
j'ai bossé huit ans sur le magazine dont
vous savez et je me suis souvent posé
cette question quel serait l'avenir du
magazine papier avec les nouvelles
technologies vous savez ce que j'ai fait
j'ai pris une caméra et j'ai fait le
tour du monde pour aller interviewer les
gens qui fabriquent ces magazines pour
savoir quelle idée izon sur le futur des
magazines papier quelle aventure
je suis allé au japon en europe aux
états-unis pour enfin faire mon film
celui ci qui s'appelle dita von teese
je les présentais en 2017 à los angeles
j'ai loué une salle de cinéma et j'ai
présenté mon film là bas c'était un
moment très intense parce que toutes les
personnes qui étaient dans ce film à
savoir les gens de la presse
les skateurs et les médias étaient venus
pour célébrer ce moment parler du
magazine c'était un moment intense parce
que j'ai dû me battre vraiment battre
parce qu'elle vous parle des beaux côtés
de ce documentaire
mais il ya aussi le côté anecdotique
pour avoir un contenu varié comme vous
savez j'ai été dans le monde entier et
j'ai dû interviewé certains médias tels
que le magazine trash heures alors
peut-être pour certains d'entre vous ce
magazine vous parle pas mais pour vous
donner un exemple c'est la bible chez
nous chez les skateurs c'est comme si je
faisais un film sur le foot et je
parlais pas de zidane donc trasher
c'était le magazine interviewé sauf que
il s'en foutait de moi j'ai envoyé un
email
deux emails pas de réponse et là je me
suis dit attends l'udc est en train de
faire un documentaire sur les médias de
skate est inclus pas trash heure là
c'est un problème
du coup ma seule solution c'était
d'aller directement sur place à san
francisco j'ai pris un billet d'avion
sans rendez-vous direction san francisco
pour à l'interviewer le magazine je
frappe à la porte
vous avez rendez vous et oui ça fait six
mois que c'est de vous parler non ça
marche pas merci au revoir je vais faire
dix heures d'avion ils m'ont foutu
dehors et monde il est tombé
j'avais deux choix soit pleurer renter
chez ma mère soit me battre j'ai fait le
campement sur steam attentes
barbecue je me suis mis devant le devant
de médias furent au bout de cinq heures
un ti delam voire de sécurité fait
qu'est ce que vous faites je voudrais
parler aux gens trasher non mais laisse
tomber par toi à part toi je passe une
nuit tout seul là bas et c'est un
quartier craignos de san francisco si tu
dois faire je suis vraiment dépité mais
je lâche pas la faire mes petites
saucisses me me remonte le moral même le
maître de sécurité me parler après t'es
sympa comme m finalement le lendemain je
vois un type passé et je crois que c'est
le boss j'interpelle comme sa sortie et
laisse moi tranquille et me dit c'est
foutu je suis en train de préparer mes
affaires je en train de tupac et là je
crois plus y'a pas devant moi j'avais
dernière carte
julie écoute je viens de france j'ai
tout donné pour rien de parler tu sais
que j'ai envoyé des idées des tonnes
d'e-mails accorde moi deux minutes il
m'a fait toi je n'oublierai jamais il
vient avec moi il m'a pas offert deux
minutes il m'a offert deux heures et m'a
raconté toute l'histoire de trash heures
cette histoire m'a rappelé que la
détermination et l'abnégation payer
toujours je suis très heureux de vous
raconter cette anecdote parce que j'ai
vraiment vécu l'enfer mais il m'a offert
ses deux heures et la compétivité
quelqu'un de sérieux
toute ma vie j'ai fait des cauchemars
vous aussi j'imagine
vous savez ces cauchemars de monstres
qui vient vous mangez les pieds et de
votre pied qui vous font peur
ben moi j'ai toujours eu peur de ces
petits monstres un jour je dessinais ces
monstres et boum comme par magie
ils se sont tous envolés est ce que
c'est ce petit monstre qui voulait me
dire
dessine-moi envole toi peut-être en tout
cas ça fait dix ans que je voyage à
travers le monde et que je peins et
dessine et que je fais ce que j'aime
tout a commencé à noël je crois il ya
une dizaine d'années exactement et j'ai
décidé de faire un dessin pour mon frère
au lieu de lui offrir un tee shirt qui
finirait dans l'oubli je me suis dit je
vais le faire quelques choses qui
m'appartenaient plus de mes mains là je
lui donne sacré comme un choc comme un
impact monde ma famille droit tu décides
non pas du tout moi j'ai jamais fait
d'école darien c'était juste pour faire
quelque chose qu'ils avaient un impact
en tout cas pour mon frère et avec du
recul
dix ans plus tard j'aime me dire que
finalement l'art est une excuse pour
aller vers l'autre parce que c'est ça
mon mojo au modjo c'est vous je fais pas
ça pour moi je fais ça pour me connecter
avec vous le lien ce personnage que vous
voyez il est drôle c'est mon personnage
s'appelle gus gus au mais on peut la
paix aussi gosse casse parce qu'en fait
si vous enlevez le gesa féroce et si
vous parler un petit peu l'anglais ça
veut dire nous et le pire le plus drôle
c'est que je n'ai pas fait
volontairement
je l'appelais gosse gosses sans savoir
qu'à vs et qui avait le partage
il sait aussi bouger sympathique
personnage
voyez là cette petite fleur et cette
fleur là est très importante pour moi
parce que c'est ce message aussi il
donne quelque chose à quelqu'un je crée
le lien avec ce personnage
il vient offrir la flore l'art m'a
permis de voyager dans le monde entier
et de faire des projets ambitieux j'ai
eu la chance d'aller partout los angeles
san francisco
[Musique]
l'asie la chine le caire l'egypte et à
travers ses voyages j'ai pu donc là je
suis aux maldives les pieds dans l'eau
réalisé des oeuvres qui encore une fois
avait un but de connexion de partage ici
c'est un petit mur de miami et voilà
tous que tout ça pour vous dire que ma
passion pour l'art vient surtout de ma
passion pour l'autre est de créer un
pont et j'ai eu la chance dont quatre à
tous ces voyages rencontrer des
personnes extraordinaires qui
m'influence et me donne encore envie de
me dépasser
je ne sais pas vous mais moi je suis
très attaché à mon adolescence 15 ans
évoque beaucoup de choses pour moi parce
qu'à 15 ans moi je rêvais j'ai toujours
mais j'arrivais beaucoup j'étais tous
les mercredis à valbonne dans une petite
place qui s'appelle la vignasse et avec
mes copains se retrouver faire du skate
c'est de notre passion on parlait
souvent de nos héros amerloques
et ouais ça vient de là bas faut pas se
cacher et je parlais d'un skateur qui
s'appelait des hwasong qu'ils appellent
d'ailleurs tour d'avon 204 jours vivent
et qui était pour moi mon idole
incroyable et owen sound
c'est un skateur américains coréens qui
m'influence toujours parce que malgré
son âge 45 ans il est toujours sûr sur
la scène vous le voyez ici donc ce
personnage m'a vraiment beaucoup
influencé imaginez si on m'avait dit
qu'à 15 ans j'allais un jour être
connecté avec mon idole lui redis
impossible attendez moyen de valbonne
j'ai un petit valbonnais se passe rien
chez moi un jour je vais être en
connexion avec lui impossible en tout
cas si on me l'avait dit j'aurais dit
que c'était impossible même brac de
prendre l'avion c'était déjà incroyable
et bien figurez vous que c'est arrivé un
soir de pleine lune 2013 mon téléphone
sonne il est minuit je bondis je regarde
mon téléphone + 1 chez ce que ça veut
dire
you may say états unis je prends le
téléphone je fais ma plus belle voix l
eau
elle a on dit c'est la marque qui se
prend cerise des monts de song le
skateboard
la planche de skate ses succès le
sponsor qui me dit bonjour on adore ce
que vous faites
on aimerait que vous fassiez la future
planches de deroin de son chéri chéri
vernétois j'ai fait un bond sur moi même
c'est comme si on m'avait annoncé que
j'avais gagné au loto ce jour-là est en
fait cette anecdote c'est pas le fruit
du hasard
c'est clairement ma passion pour le
skate qui m'a permis d'atteindre mes
rêves des rêves j'en ai plein c'est une
boucle qui se régénère sans cesse et qui
revient vous en avez des rêves où moi je
vais vous raconter une histoire
incroyable pour finir c'est l'histoire
du chauffeur de taxi qui rêvait d'être
prof de kung fu c'est original quand
même sauf que ça m'est arrivé je suis à
londres à l'aéroport
je prends un taxi direction le centre
est là j'adore discuter avec les gens
vous le savez j'aime les autres je me
mets à discuter avec le chauffeur de
taxi il me demande ce que je fais ici et
je lui dis pas j'ai une expo à londres
ce formidable et il me dit waouh c'est
génial
oui j'ai d'autres passions ça doit être
super et moi parce que je trouve que ce
qui est sympa c'est quand vous posez une
question faut toujours la rendre et vous
quel est votre passion et là je sens
qu'ils voient c'est un peu les épaules
et me dit ma passion c'est le kung fu un
chauffeur de taxi qui est passionné par
kung fu génial et je lui dis pourquoi
vous faites pas du kung fu du coup et là
il me dit maintenant ben faut de la
cloris ma famille là ça m'a fait tilt
j'ai compris à quel point la société
nous imposer à faire des choses qu'on
aimait pas forcément ça a fait beaucoup
de peine d'ailleurs je me suis dit
'pourquoi hobby devrait forcément rester
un hobby pourquoi au contraire un hobby
ne deviendrait pas notre travail notre
passion parce qu'on a cette idée que le
travail est forcément quelque chose de
dieu on va au travail on va au bagne
c'est terrible quand même cette idée
ça me rappelle
le dimanche je pense que ça va évoquer
quelque chose à tout le monde c'est
dimanche à demain c'est lundi que
j'aille travailler brive y penser ça me
fait froid dans le dos du coup on
discute et là j'ai une idée qui me vient
et je lui dis mais pourquoi le dimanche
prochain aux habitants y ait pas trois
de vos amis aller au parc et l'aurait
sénile tous les basiques et en
contrepartie la semaine d'après ils
doivent revenir avec un autre ami et
vous et comment ça se développe
j'arrive à londres je laisse ma carte
merci à bientôt peut-être six mois plus
tard je reçois un texto du chauffeur de
taxi et là il ya une photo qui m'a
bouleversé
il était en kimono avec 40 personnes
devant lui dans le parc
il m'a dit merci là j'ai vécu une
émotion extraordinaire
je me suis dit il m'a écouté et il a
vécu son rêve je puis de nouvelles mais
en tout cas ce moment là était très
intense dans la vie tout est possible le
tout est de le vouloir et leur donner
les moyens
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]